well here we go
[Applause]
about that time baby about that time
[Music]
there you go baby
tonight is a night okay well I
downloaded that song and I didn't I
thought it was just about I thought it
was just entrance tremendum and I
thought it was just gonna be about uh
about snow and apparently it's about
December so you know I'm not trying to
be a time traveler so I'm gonna shut it
down um good morning good day good
evening whatever time it is for you
grateful to be here today with you
it is a February February 11th in the
year 2019 and um and it's snowing dude
it is snowed up over here I mean it is
really snowy and I'm in Columbus Ohio
and snow is why oh man think about snow
think about snow
I mean snow what is it
we don't know I mean we know that - you
know - cold things you know they started
doing sex or something up way up in the
sky and next thing you know they snow
and they're you know they start shedding
little snow you know just spraying out a
little bit of snow out of them
and that's beautiful man and it's really
nice just hitting everywhere out here
snow they got snow snowmen people are
building snowman snow women they got a
transgender you know they put a cup
of uh you know they took the carrot off
of it and put like just you know like a
little you know somebody put over the
crops one of those um you know like a
Rubik's Cube so anything could happen
down there in the crotch for some of the
snowmen and people are just enjoying the
time out hearing and I'm here in the
middle of America in Columbus Ohio and
it's snowing I didn't think it was gonna
be snowing you know I was taking a nap
and I was dreaming about you know I was
saw I was where was I was at a um Kurt
right a curtain shop you know and I was
looking at different curtains and stuff
and and then next thing you know I wake
up and I'm thinking you know I'm not
thinking anything cuz I just woke up I
thought I was looking for curtains you
know but really I'm [ __ ] in a in a
hotel and then I come and look out the
window in his snow and man it's
beautiful and it's wild to think that
weird is on this planet we're on a ball
of dirt and water in the middle of
nowhere and suddenly a bunch of cold
[ __ ] falls on you I mean you can't man
what is it what's going on is there a
greater plan I wish I depicted a better
intro song but sometimes you don't pick
the right intro music you know I
remember that on my grandfather's
funeral you somebody the DJ accidentally
played that song it was a Ludacris song
when he Ludacris saying it was the one
where he dresses up like in the videos
with like the Ludacris you know he have
the UM
the incredible whole hands-on anyway but
imagine you being there at the
grandfather's funeral and they got that
you know to DJ Oh get back he played
Ludacris get back get back get back you
don't know me like that
and my grandfather's funeral he did you
know the guy messed up at the wake they
had like a musical guy at the wake and
next thing you know everybody's like
Jesus you know they're like man that old
do must have been into some wild [ __ ] if
he's listening to if they're playing
Ludacris at his funeral but but good to
be here with you guys man I had quite a
weekend here I've been here in Columbus
Ohio thank you to everybody that came
out you know I always say that and and
man it's just been great I still have a
shows tonight it's Sunday right now and
what have I been doing
you know it's Sunday I uh I'm thinking
about maybe going for a run
I um indoors dude I ain't running
outdoors in the snow that'd be crazy if
my legs were nicer I would do it if my
legs were nicer I would do it I would
get out there I think but yeah a lot of
great people have come out a lot of
people with blue eyes and I don't know
if there's something going on you know
if more I mean this one guy came out the
other night with D but you know he's
just [ __ ] baby blue just balls of the
lords [ __ ] booyah base in his face
this dude had just oh man you if you
looked in his eye you didn't you didn't
know where you were
you could be molested or you know or
anything while you were looking at you
don't even know somebody steal your
shirt still your you know your 401k they
take everything they'll take the stairs
off your house they'll take the front
stair walking you'll open the door him
[ __ ] fall face-first out into the
[ __ ] I mean this dude had some just blue
hitters in his face I don't know what I
mean it looked like like he'd stolen him
out of a museum like he hired Nicolas
Cage to go out there and find him a set
of eyes cuz this dude had some I mean
just like just like little pieces of
Plymouth Rock somebody'd put him in his
damn fate in his head I mean I would had
a dude if I had eyes that nice I'd have
a [ __ ] Doberman Pinscher out there
watching him you know I'd have a damn
Rottweiler
dude I'd have a up would have a
Rottweiler watching my eyes at all times
because I'd be worried somebody's gonna
show up with a sharp spoon and just
scoop me out and to wear my visuals
around their neck you know somebody you
know one of those people in a fancy you
know a dictator or somebody like that
maybe somebody in Africa one of those
you know Sierra Leone one of those
people that are stealing you know
whatever doing all of that I'm gonna
tell you about a couple things though
some updates you know today is the day
we're going to announce those Australia
dates and I'm so excited man I can't
even imagine that I'm gonna go to
Australia and that's so bizarre to think
that I'm gonna go to our to another
country and that people are gonna come
out to see the shows that's just
battling it's that's just beyond I can't
even I don't know how it makes sense you
know I don't even know how it makes
sense but I'm really excited about it
I'm gonna let you know this right now
you know today's episode is brought to
you by grey block pizza in great block
pizza that's a pairi you know that's a
pie you know please didn't make special
pies over there in Los Angeles
18:11 Pico Boulevard all the weight of
the B grey block get that hitter I also
want to let you know that today's
episode is brought to you by by um hold
on I'm getting this audio right by our
small business sponsor and this is a
book and it's called the meathead
manifesto and it is written by Brody
McVitie
sorry Brody McVitie and if you want to
support a small business like we do and
I'll tell you it man I checked out the
meathead manifesto by Brody McVitie and
this guy makes reading about fitness
actually enjoyable it's a how-to book
it's a how-to book for people who have
no [ __ ] clue what they're doing in
the gym okay
Brody covers topics like how to tell if
your personal trainer
is a straight-up d-bag how to tell if
you're a d-bag client if you're a dowser
Baghdady
if you're a dowser bagman and you got to
tighten up but one of y'all is probably
a douse bag the meathead manifesto is
the only how-to guide you'll ever need
if you're in a bodybuilding and girls
and nutrition then you'll love this
irreverent take on concepts like how to
handle your raging jealousy and fad like
the stuff you need not what you are and
that's how to get good fats you know
it's funny a lot of different nuts and
everything have good fats in them and
that's what I used to see you know if a
girl was thinking about giving me a
[ __ ] I said you know nuts really got
a lot of healthy fat in them so there's
that but you can head on over to Brody's
website WWD McVitie MC vit TI e dot-com
or at brody drew BR ody dr e w on
instagram and click on the this past
weekend section for a special discounted
copy of the book today
that's Brody McVitie BR OD y MC vit TI e
dot-com and head to the this past
weekend section for a special discounted
copy of the meathead manifesto and I
used to be a meathead man I used to get
you know I used to get straight-up damn
media out there dude
so you can support small businesses like
we do here at this past weekend and that
is a small business advertisement right
there an author and everybody's wanted
to write a book and that man went when
and did it that's that meathead
manifesto and you know you've seen these
beasts he's in the gym you know some
dude got it you know I mean just you
know he's just done so many reps he just
you know he does curls and all the
pimples on his paint on his face pop at
once just
you know shatters his [ __ ] tastebuds
everything just flies right out of his
mouth you know thing just hit you know
just creaming out of his own pores you
know he's all hopped up on protein
powder one of those guys that's usually
a lot of times you'll see them like
dripping liquid protein into their
eyeballs and you know some of them will
even take a damn Mac nugget and you know
do them suppositories just to get a
couple extra grams in the old be whole
you know they're like that people that
just gotta have a protein someone will
[ __ ] suck an egg right out of a
chicken's booty you know it just to get
that extra six grams it's enough that's
in an egg and you know an egg has 6
grams of protein in it isn't that pretty
well and then I guess it's not that wild
actually so but let's get in I'm going
to announce the days in just a minute
let's get into a call or two real quick
that came in here we go Gang Gang Nick
and Dylan and upstate New York that is
neck tat country so if you ever wondered
you know do I have a neck tat or what
does it seem like to have a neck tattoo
well go to upstate New York and meet a
couple ladies or a couple men and you
know sometime they'll have turtlenecks
if they if they're ashamed of himself
and you got to peel down that turtleneck
and Kasese that they got a picture of
you know like a little do some time uh
you know if it's a guy that's been a
prisoner left like a weird mix a [ __ ]
like a gun and then like a little Mickey
Mouse and a Minnie Mouse or something
sometimes ladies we'll have like a soup
spoon or you know a garbage plate or
something if they're from Rochester I'll
have that tattoo to stack a meat and
cheese on her neck thank you for calling
fellas homeward icy podcast throw that
I'm a big fan of Corey gee Johnny Bosco
and Mo see you know I follow of course
G's workouts the dude is insane for what
he does works all those guys you know
they got some good [ __ ] going on there
and I was just wondering what you take
those guys what you learned and apply to
your life I think it's helped a lot with
my personal development growth so yeah
it's when what you learn stem Gang Gang
homie gang papa thank you for the other
call and you know what this is what I
did while I was here you know there
wasn't a lot of time cuz here's the
thing like I fly into Columbus right I
lose three hours on the flight so I
leave at 6 a.m. you know I got up at
4:45 right and I'm not complaining I'm
grateful because I get to do something
that I love I get to come and see a lot
of dope people and some real
questionable people as well but you know
I get out there and next thing you know
I fly here so you lose at 3 hours you
get off the plane you get to the hotel
you get settled you hit the aah
you hit the shows you know and you do it
like that and you barely got a time to
get a little bit of you know you know to
put some fresh and on your skin or get
freshened up or to even really you know
fold your clothes or something and I
don't like to take my clothes out of my
bag when I'm traveling I don't I'll keep
my clothes in my bag dude I don't even
know whose furniture this is when I'm in
the hotel room whose [ __ ] furniture
is it not mine bro you think I'm putting
my furniture in your you know little
shiver robe or drawer set so what if I
leave it you get my [ __ ] bro a lot of
these furniture these think they're dust
traps like hey won't you forget some
[ __ ] in this thing over here oh here's a
nice place for you to forget some [ __ ]
that that you that you probably really
want to not forget that's what all it is
man why do you think everything in a
motel or hotel has drawers and stuff on
it because they want you to leave [ __ ]
Oh what is that you left that oh you oh
you left that a little bit of cash lepor
wallet [ __ ] somebody left a Bible I
was in a half these places you know you
left a little frigerator somebody left
and one of these are you know I was at
these um you know the Ambassador suite
and they had a somebody
for [ __ ] for a little probably
someday I can redneck you know it boy
some beautiful [ __ ] brought it down
you know a little Frigidaire you know
somebody that I guess want to have cold
you know cold cuts or whatever close to
them and they're laughing in a damn I
don't know why they even put it in there
but they [ __ ] you know people like
that you know real people they do real
[ __ ] like put a Frigidaire in a damn
chest of drawers but that's all uh hotel
them's just a place for you to lose [ __ ]
drop an earring lose a wedding ring
you know the bedsheets if you lose just
you ever lost a sock have you ever lost
a sock in a motel bed sheet area do take
your socks off where you go to bed leave
them in the bed with you you'll never
see those [ __ ] again right they just
[ __ ] straight-up Narnia down at the
bottom they got nineteen layers of
sheets that she's in [ __ ] is young I
tell you it is probably one of the but
people that you know the cleaning lady
or somebody that works at the front desk
the night manager he always got a white
you know probably
his name is mr. Patrick or something
that [ __ ] up there wearing your
socks by morning you know the sock fairy
comes and just just socks yo [ __ ] out in
a sock shoe harassment bruh grade a
hashtag feet to baby feet to I mean I
tell you that's what I'm saying these
these rooms are built to steal your [ __ ]
the carpet is always a special pattern
you set someone you never see it again
it could be anything
you set a damn four-year-old on the
floor you'll never see me blend right it
in and a damn carpet so you got to be
careful because motel rooms is set up to
steal your [ __ ]
but anyway oh you asked the business of
my CEPS crew I went over there and I did
an episode of their podcast and man it
was great you know it was something that
I really needed actually uh and those
guys are Maurice Clarett John Fusco and
and Corey G and one of them is a male
model you know which is is what it is
but as you know they're good people
Maurice Clarett is a famed athlete and a
and he works with people in recovery and
people you know getting their lives on
track and people getting themselves
better emotionally acclimated to the
world and John Fosco does the marketing
he was marketing for UFC for a long time
with Dana White and now he does he's had
some of his own businesses they're all
businessmen and they're based out of
here in Ohio and they came on my pod on
this on this this this past weekend
about six months ago and and I was happy
man we had a great time
drove out there they got a cool studio
and we kicked it and you know I got a
lot more from them honestly than I was
really expecting now for Maurice I feel
he is a I mean he is just like he's like
the Garden of Eden
when it comes to being able to I think
really offer clear and concise and
relatable help to people that struggle
so him I kind of you know I like him
he's like there's this fountain of truth
a little bit you can go around and you
know it's just he has some real special
gifts so I love listening to him and the
other two guys you know it's I didn't
know what I was gonna get sometimes I
mean I've listened to some episodes of
their pod but but this it was really
great man you know they talked about
what's going on with me with business
and and just sometimes how I feel like
what keeps me from maybe achieving some
of my dreams like really just like
embracing that there's a confidence of
just modern you know just like saying
this is mine you know this this is my
destiny and you know not second-guessing
myself and really trying to be more of
um I guess not being afraid to be a
leader of myself really you know not of
others but really just to be able to not
be afraid to lead
self so it was interesting it left me
with a lot of things to think about and
it was great it was honestly a really I
thought it was a real heartfelt episode
so and it was nice to not have to steer
the show and just to be a to be a guest
you know I like being a guest you know
um you know it's funny all my life I've
liked being a guest I love going over to
people's houses I love being you know
always get more nervous when people come
into my area and I do better when I go
into somebody else's area but it was
many it was it was great it was one of
the it was one of the best times I've
had on a podcast and that's saying a lot
cuz I've you know been able to be
fortunate and listen to some real guys
and share some time with some real
different pods um but thanks for calling
Gang Gang man and I just added some
dates actually in New York City and
that's me I think third and fourth or
fourth and fifth let's take this call
that came in right here here we go hello
Joel that's not that's a British accent
I'm sorry I'm not gonna try to
impersonate your accent hello George
thank you for calling mate um I'm
calling because I have a whole heap of
spare time on my hands and I get this
one song into this vodka well better
than masturbating and just touching
yourself and that's what I used to do
but I think right now I'm like 70 days
off of no masturbation pornography sorry
I [ __ ] came recently but all for
pornography
you know I bust still but I'm not
watching them them titty videos you feel
me let's hear more doors know what to do
with all this time what what do you
think if you had all this spare time you
got heaps of free time what would you do
like I'd learn a skill go surfing who
knows cheers keep up the good work
George do well first of all if I was in
Australia and I had free time I would
try to do that
and get a little bit of that that
[ __ ] kanga belly you feel me every
time I leave this on what's wrong with
me I would try to get that kanga belly
where you sneak up on a kangaroo and try
to get your hand in that little freaking
my man you know internet that pocket
ma'am boy hit him with that bounce and
get one hand in there if you can and if
you can if you get two hands in there
bro you're going to heaven you know that
if you look if you can approach a
stranger ooh that's what I call him a
kangaroo you don't know cuz do kangaroo
sir fight okay there's a I mean
kangaroos are the damn
you know the George st. Pierre's of
[ __ ] you know the Far East Australia
and they will they fight
did you put a couple dollars down
between two kangaroos they'll beat the
[ __ ] out of each other man I mean it's
like I mean it's wild you know this is
some damn you know they're real animals
but if you get that one hand in there in
that pocket if you get both hands in
that kangaroo pocket boy you're going to
heaven dude and that's that KP challenge
brought it that kangaroo pocket
challenge see if you could sneak up on a
stranger ooh one you don't know and get
both hands in its pocket good luck with
that [ __ ] but what would I do in my
spare time brother I will tell you right
now I would I'd probably go visit I'll
probably go see Theo von in Australia
and the dates that I'm gonna be there
are Fri every time
Friday May 24th in Melbourne of
Melbourne Melbourne on Melbourne
Australia at Gold Fields Theatre
Saturday May 25th at the Metro Theatre
in Sydney
Sunday May 26th in Perth at the Astor
Theatre Astor Theatre and Saturday June
1st in Brisbane at the Plaza auditorium
so I'm very excited Melbourne Sydney
Perth and Brisbane goldfields theatre
Metro Theatre Astra theater and Plaza
auditorium man that's correct I mean
this is just wild you know to think that
I'm gonna go to Australia and do shows
man I'm so excited and you know I'm
nervous I guess cuz I don't know if you
know I'm just worried like what if some
of the jugs don't go or people don't
know what I'm talking about but I guess
I can just try and think about it before
and uh and do my best day you know and
do my best so pretty cool man I'm really
honored and I'm really really excited as
well we had New York dates just went on
sale those tickets at Caroline's on
Broadway May 3rd and 4th otherwise West
Palm Beach Kansas City Phoenix San Jose
Atlantic City and the new shows Boston
Medford in Medford Massachusetts at the
Chevallier theater otherwise I'll see
you in Houston February 21st and 23rd so
thank you so much to you from everything
from Australia man I've gotten I bet
I've gotten probably 600 DMS about
people asking and you know and just
asking me to come and so you know I feel
honored to feel welcome and thank you
very much and I'm kind of scared I'm
excited you know this is just crazy man
you know it's crazy that I get to live
my dreams and you know and I do want I
want to try and work on just being more
confident and just embracing you know
embracing my dreams and not feeling bad
about sometimes I feel bad about the
opportunities that I have or that I'm
getting for some reason it's so weird
man you know I feel bad about the
opportunities I feel like I don't know
sometimes I just feel like ashamed of of
even getting good opportunities you know
it's just something that's in my head
that
you know that doesn't want me to feel
good almost about anything sometimes and
that's my alcoholism that's my you know
that's that negative self tape and that
was one thing we talked about on the
business and biceps podcast and I don't
work for those guys or ever that's just
yeah I think they're a special group now
John Bosco will get on your [ __ ]
nerves sometimes but but then other
episodes he will be your absolute
favorite so he's kind of like a stepdad
you know sometimes you're like this
[ __ ] guy but other times you're like
that [ __ ] guy wow what else man but
that's your answer what I would do in my
spare time I would go see theof on at
one of those places in Australia and I'm
so happy to be announced in those dates
I can't even believe it I'm like really
just keyed up [ __ ] man I feel like
buying a damn eight-ball bra you know
but what else do I like to do in my
spare time things I would really like to
do we're finishing the pilot shoot this
week we got Jim Jeffries um his is gonna
be on an episode so Wow so excited about
that
speaking of Australia you know the
Australian and the British Sun you know
the dual citizen mr. Jay Jeffries and
sorry this episodes a little choppy man
I'm by myself I set the camera up by
myself you know I'm not in the studio so
you know I don't even know if this [ __ ]
if you can hear it so good luck but I
want to take this calm and you guys will
be happy to hear this and what a
blessing we got a call from from my boy
today right here trick along Mickey
everybody's been asking about him and
this was a gentleman we met about a year
and a half ago that had a cystic
fibrosis you know he had them [ __ ]
danger bags bro his lungs was all shook
out and beat down and the devil was just
trying to grow [ __ ] dirty Spanish
moss up in the sides of his air cages
and then something came up you know and
then the Lord went looking for the boy
and he got new lungs baby
he got them new [ __ ] Oh two hitters
in him then [ __ ] baby [ __ ] breasty
bags bro you know them [ __ ] silly
silly
sack said he's got and he's puffing on
some [ __ ] bad motor scooters right
now and I've been asking him to call in
and and he did and man listen to his
voice even sounds better um you know
what here you go
yo what's up field man this is trick
love Nicky hey man just giving you a
call to uh to check in and give you an
update to my life and everything man my
health has been it's been crazy dude
it's been great ever since my recovery
things have been just absolutely amazing
I had a really amazing recovery went
real fast I got healthy real quick and
and nowadays Nano just relearning how to
live life again I'm just trying to
relearn you know how to job recently and
I quit that job because on that truck
jobs right but then I also started
dating again and y'all working out
boxing here and there and man life is
going good and I just want to reach out
to you and tell you how things have been
and we have talked a little bit and yeah
man thank you so much do to everybody
with listened and and gave me any
messages or anything like that until you
very much feel and then I Love You Man
and here we go live in a real life and
I'm going to excited to be able to do
something that I'll check you later dude
Wow
in that coal man living a real life and
you know what we're gonna have Mickey in
studio sometime soon and I wish if I had
the capabilities this week I would go
back and play some of his old calls up
some of his old where you can you know
he did know if he was gonna live man he
really didn't you know and he was high
he was like I think in the top couple on
the transplant list and it was you know
coming down to it and he was in ICU for
a long time and and then it came through
you know it came through and they hit
him with them [ __ ] puff wings brother
him lungs and he got a set of them
freaking bad [ __ ] ribcage roller
skates you know then [ __ ] baby back
chimneys son and now listen to him he
said he's dating bro you know we got
there bust a nut boy and man he should
be
you know imagine how much good nut you
got locked up in your body I mean I
can't even oh if you got bad lungs you
could probably barely get any seed out
of your body or probably just you know
kind of climbs out a little at a time
you know like a couple people you know
getting out of like a you know if a
truck turned over on his side and
everybody's son and get out one of the
windows but now he's out there and he's
got some real heat you know he's got
them heat sacks in him and he's flowing
big I bet and he's dating he quit a job
dude [ __ ] yeah brah that's that's the
best living baby telling somebody off
[ __ ] you I'm leaving and then going back
the next day man like hey man I'm really
you know I need this job back that's it
man you're living that's living that's
awesome that's awesome and I want to
hear about that I would love to have him
it man he was his you know Mickey's take
was so clear on like what what he was so
honest about some of the thoughts and
feelings he was having about all about
when he wasn't doing well and when he
wasn't sure he was gonna make it and he
came out to my shows and he looked man
he know he look kind of Italian but also
kind of like amphibian you know he was
because you get kind of jaundice you
know you turn a little bit a bit of
jaundice you know the devil puts out a
yellow number 17 when they take me in
unit long sorbet when you got dirty
Long's and he was shook out but uh man
it's so good to hear his voice you look
just listen to how good he sounds even
Paul to uh to check in give you an
update to my life and everything and my
health has been it's been crazy listen
to the octaves on that boy he's [ __ ]
hitting different levels he's finished
he couldn't make it through a sentence
this dude couldn't make it through a
sentence I mean he was like the Ted
Bundy a sentences he would escape or
just die you know he couldn't make it
through a sentence but now here he is
dropping full paragraphs Amen baby let's
take another call here this came in
on the hotline 95 six six four nine five
zero three
thank you guys always for calling
[Music]
Spencer from Ogden Utah what's up
Spencer from Ogden Utah now Utah is one
of the states that have a lot of secret
jewels in the ground and you know
special ores gold homewards
in game I want you to show in Salt Lake
it was amazing by the way but I just
listened to that Howie Mandel podcast
and you talked about identical twins and
they have to fight it out cuz it's
witchcraft re and whatnot but I have a
twin brother named ourselves number
twenty-four years old and but we're
fraternal so I want to ask you do we
have to fight to the death because if we
do I'm kind of [ __ ] he's got a bigger
dick than me probably like six inches
bigger he lives dude six inches bigger
that's then you don't have any day so do
you have a dick or not would be probably
where to start let's move onward I
appreciate you sharing though some of
this weight he has a girlfriend she's
got a lot of good stuff going for him
and I'm just I'm just here listening to
podcast hell I love your podcast laugh
so I don't know if that's good or let me
know if paternal twins can stay alive we
need to fight to the death
well I'll say this but I mean in my book
you win because I'd love to keep you as
a as somebody that's part of the curious
crew that absorbs these episodes you
know he's got a girlfriend people have
done that that's not a real New Deal you
know he's gone on a jabra well that's
good everybody should have a job
everybody should work he but yeah man
look if y'all look here's the thing if
y'all look the same man y'all are
[ __ ] with people really what you're
doing is just long-term magic oh he's
there now I'm there you know who's that
oh yeah you know you know your names are
Randy and Landy
like get the [ __ ] out here with all of
that they'll figure it out
just cuz y'all you know just keep your
mom's vagina kind of stuttered both
y'all out of that I mean everybody else
has said have to be all confused so look
man if you if you're identical twins do
I think y'all should take shifts but
having both y'all out in the world at
the same time isn't fair so if you want
to fight it out or do it out man I don't
blame you brah cuz whatever else y'all
are doing y'all are hey there's no way
you could live a full life
if somebody over there livin half your
life hmm what do you think I am man
you think I was born in 1961 bruh no sir
but you know so maybe challenge him to
some real [ __ ] you challenge him to some
[ __ ] you could win you know like maybe
do a staring contest if he's stronger
start with the husba you don't know
who's strong you know you never know he
he probably don't do like a lot of eye
exercises you know a lot of optical
chart work so hit him where it [ __ ]
hurts man you know you start to know
some [ __ ] about him do some seance and
or somethin Ouija board his ass dude
he's half of you running around and
you're just [ __ ] chillin bro tighten
up dude but I appreciate you calling man
I appreciate you calling in with that
information and just I can't imagine if
somebody if I look over and they got
somebody just like me and they got a
girl with big tits boom and I'm just
over here just looking at my own meat
and sometimes like drawing little
nipples on my nuts and kind of squeeze
them into the end of the bag so it looks
like like a little set of tits burn I
mean this that's wild man it's snowing
out here it's beautiful I'm going on
strike yeah dude if you [ __ ] double
hand that [ __ ] que pocket son Oh
straight to heaven let's hear this
onward
these little best friends with my other
parent
oh yeah ferrets like having buddies if
you see one fair by itself man oh so sad
you see two ferrets always running all
over each other no urinate on each other
if you want to watch something urinate
on each other and it's not people brah
you know you're not an Amsterdam or
something you got you know you got some
time to kill or something way your wife
shopping then you got to get two ferrets
cuz in bag cats will piss all over each
other bra I mean it's like damn I mean
it's just like it's like a you know
that's the Lord's lemonade stand rather
a pair of ferrets thank you for calling
in and thank you for calling from Reno
and if you also want to I mean Reno just
a lot of AAA meetings and unemployment
over there a lot of disability checks
Boyd a lot of debility checks hitting
hitting mailboxes of it in Reno boy
beautiful visually beautiful landscaped
lot of AAA meetings if you're trying to
get better brah go to Reno were slot
machines in the world Laughlin and Reno
do people I was there for a whole
weekend two times nobody won
nothin let's take more all word now I
could see that I could see me looking
like a ferret you know I'm kind of lean
kind of longing in a nose got hair on my
chinny-chin-chin so yeah I could see
that I wet the bed laws about 28 so I
think you made a good choice you know I
mean you could be the damn mayor Reno as
far as I'm concerned it sound like you
made a real solid choice there and thank
you for blessing that animal of my name
and I'd love to meet that animal some
point you know someone uh someone months
ago sent me a picture of a Chinese kid
and they named him Theo von and I
thought that was pretty cool
this is like a year actually it's about
a year and a half ago so now we got a
Chinese you know a young
Chinese and a ferret so pretty cool
let's take a call right here nine eight
five six six four nine five zero three
is the hotline and thank you to
everybody that came out in Columbus this
weekend I don't know if I express that
enough I know I always do that on these
but y'all don't realize like the the
people that work at these clubs
constantly tell me man you're you have
the best audiences they're like they're
just good people they come in they're
enjoying the show and they're having fun
and uh and it's just man it's cool you
know it's really cool and I feel
grateful too just to meet everybody I
get to meet you know this dude's sit oh
I met two twins this weekend and look
man what date I was like man y'all need
a funny y'all need to just shut it down
I mean maybe if y'all in different
hemispheres I could see it working but
with both y'all in the same place it
seems like cheating what else do we have
come out we had I mean everybody people
drove him from Pittsburgh Cleveland
people drove in met people that I'd seen
before at the shows in Nashville and
then I saw him here you know we had some
people from recovery came out man and uh
some really great people just a good
just a good time you know I'm pretty
fortunate young man to be able to make
you guys laugh and I hope I did that
let's take this hitter here here we go
hi my name is Jessica and I'm Arizona oh
thank you for calling Jessica that's my
mother lives in Tucson and she just put
her she just put her husband in a in an
Alzheimer's unit
because you gots Alzheimer's let's hear
more but I felt compelled to call
because even though our occupations are
very different I feel that there's some
similarities I felt like I needed to
call and send you some love well thank
you that's sweet of you you know my
sister's a nurse and I think it's one of
the most amazing jobs you can have not
not because my sister has it but I just
you know a lot of nurses that I met are
just amazing people you know they have
ability an ability to care about others
not just at work but even in the regular
lives and it's just like a it's just
like it's like you and I breathing it's
just like a natural thing for them and
um a man it's just it's special they're
special people they have a special gift
to care for others that really I admire
let's hear more you're talking about the
dream you had with helping your
neighbors find their keys and you're
talking about being tired but I know
nurses can experience what they call a
caregiver burnout and that happens when
you give of yourself consistently and
forget for neglect to take care of
yourself and I feel like for like you do
that too
you're always giving of yourself of your
time and your energy and making people
laugh which is a beautiful thing I just
felt like maybe practicing some
self-love and bye self-love I mean for
me I I work out I do boxing and that is
a great outlet for me and listening to
podcast like yours really helps a lot
too so that's about it I just wanted to
tell you I love you and thank you for
what you do you're you're a bright light
in this world well you are you know
you're much more light than I will ever
be you are a nurse you know and being by
people's bedside when they're really
scared man that's a real powerful and
brave placed
you know they should call y'all
lifeguards people buy pool gets a
lifeguard hey that dude ain't doing [ __ ]
bro he up there trying to [ __ ] honestly
you know or it's some lady up there
trying to show off her legs and put the
tanning on them you know the shine you
know the oil they all should be the
lifeguards and you all should get the
whistle and if somebody about to die you
whistle at them and they just pop right
back up cuz nurses are the real
lifeguards you know you only sitting up
there and you got a here's the thing if
you were a lifeguard at a pool
somebody's drowning you throw them that
little thing that little you know hey Do
It Yourself cheerio but I'll brah but
nurse you got to figure it out you got
to make choices quick you know y'all
should get you know they should give
y'all a cut you know uh syringe of HGH
or something if there's somebody's
passing out just you know Dexter I'm in
the net and just bring them back real
fast and get them going but it's just I
always leave my email on yes but yes for
some reason it's always they get all the
credit lifeguards and y'all are the real
lifeguards nurses and for some reason
yeah they get all the credit but you
guys are the real lifeguards you know
I'll tell you this if I'm in the deep
end of a disease I don't want some dude
over there you know or some lady with
them big daddies out there Brenda or
something you know and she just putting
tanning oil on her body you know where
it is or some dude with bangs over his
face he can't even see I'm [ __ ]
drowning and he's over here just looking
all just quaffed out and
well-conditioned he got sunglasses over
two bangs and he's a lifeguard
[ __ ] that dude I next time I'm at a pool
burn bring in a nurse brah we're gonna
are in and ugly no that's what I'm doing
real life savers so sorry I got fired up
about that right there let me tell you
this
I'm gonna tell you this right here that
this past weekend is brought to you by
zip recruiter zip recruiter used to be
hard remember finding somebody for
something man
hard to do you get to go door-to-door
you did put a message in a bottle hey
honey you know I need somebody that can
make cement and throw the bottle out you
know out of the car while you're driving
these two have multiple job sites stacks
of resumes and a confusing review
process
but today hiring can be easy and you
only have to go to one place to get it
done zip recruiter dot-com slash tpw
that's right zip recruiter com slash tpw
zip recruiter sends your job Doe over
100 of the web's leading job boards but
they don't stop there with powerful
matching technology zip recruiter scans
thousands of resumes to find people with
the right experience and invite them to
apply to your job as applications come
in zip recruiter analyzes each one and
spotlights the top candidates so you
never miss a great match zip recruiter
is so effective that 80% of employers
who post on zip recruiter get a quality
candidate through the site within the
first day need someone specific for
something specific get the best
candidate zip recruiter right now my
listeners can try zip recruiter for free
at this exclusive web address zip zip
zip recruiter dot-com slash tpw that's
zip recruiter dot-com slash t pw zip
recruiter the smartest way to hire as
well you know if you're running business
if you're making some money you need to
take care of yourself you have a long
term goals for yourself and your loot
well I'm here to tell you that Robin
Hood is an investing app that lets you
buy and sell stocks ETFs options and
cryptos all commissioned free while
other brokerages charge up to $10 what
for every trade Robin Hood doesn't
charge any Commission fee
you can trade stocks and keep all your
profits plus there's no account minimum
deposit needed to get started so you can
start investing at any level the simple
intuitive designer robin hood makes
investing easy for newcomers and experts
alike view easy to understand charts and
market data you can also view stock
collections such as the 100 most popular
with robin hood you can learn how to
invest in the market as you build your
portfolio and robin hood you can
discover new stocks track your favorite
companies get custom notifications for
price movements so you never miss the
right moment to invest robin hood is
giving listeners of this past weekend a
free stock like Apple Ford or Sprint to
help you build your portfolio
sign up at Weekend dot Robin Hood
dot-com that's weekend dot Robin Hood
dot-com take care of yourself long term
have some plans don't be too risky but
or do be risky but but you know if you
want to invest that seems like a good
place to do it
oh I'll tell you this man Valentine's
Day is right around the corner I said
loved a man and I wish I might I might
maybe I'll do a Valentine's episode
Valentine's Day is right around the
corner weather and rather than spending
all Ladd moolah
going out to fancy restaurants why not
just hang in your underwear all night
courtesy of me undies
me undies uses the coveted micro mode a
fabric which is three times softer than
cotton this fabric genuinely feels like
actual heaven against your skin like the
Lord just you know cut off about just a
couple ounces of heaven and just set it
on your butter or near your crotch or
legs or hips you can also get a style
that is perfectly suited for you men and
women can each choose from four
different cuts all of which are
available from classic colors too
adventurous prints speaking of prints
this V day and that means of Valentine's
Day not VD which is not as good
but if your Valentine's Day goes well
you might get a little VD you feel me
but speaking of prints this vide a
season me undies will be releasing a new
print every Tuesday but why stop at
undies this year my undies is launching
their video prints in lounge pants and
onesies as well look nothing's cuter
than you and your lo buckaroo laying
around and a [ __ ] bang onesie
because here's what's fun make one of
them onesies a-to-z you feel me this is
a no-brainer get 15% off the most
comfortable undies you will ever put on
to get your 15% off your first pair free
shipping and 100% satisfaction guarantee
go to meet undies dot-com slash weekend
that's me undies dot-com slash weekend
and thank you guys for uh supporting
this past weekend if there's you know if
you want to support the podcast and
you're not a you know doing patron and
you don't know how and that's one of the
ways you can do it I go support my own
podcast I use the codes and I go to the
different places and I use these things
you know because I believe in what I'm
doing and so I want to support the
companies that support us because
they're advertising through us and thank
you guys for any you guys who have used
these companies and I love me undies and
and I and I'm happy to be here with you
guys today alright thank you nurse for
culminating and you know you're right
I'm gonna try to do so maybe less
Thursday episodes and I got to slow it
down a little bit cuz I'm just uh you
know I've been feeling a little bit
overwhelmed and some of its fear of
messing up and fear of not doing stuff
some of its what uh you know I've had to
go from being a comedian just a guy
screwing around to more of a guy like
running you know his future I think and
right now is a real transition period
for me and uh and so it's been different
you know I used to just be the guy I
could just show up at the club and do
the sets and go home and um
and now people are there and so have a
responsibility and and then also you
know people are like oh well I want to
get a shirt and so you want to have
merchandise but you want to have fair
price merchandise and you won't have
good merchandise so you know you try and
deal with stuff like that and then you
know you I want to start a kid's channel
so that I can entertain you know do fun
stuff for children that could be
entertaining or or or or seek out some
you know help other friends that want to
create stuff for children and you know I
want to do you know some outreach I want
to help others I don't want to be
someone that gets opportunities and just
takes for themselves so I want to you
know try and do this kind of stuff and
it's like suddenly I feel like a lot of
pressure to do it all at once and I
don't know I guess I just feel I think
some of the truth is that us feel like
if I don't constantly do something then
people aren't going to see that I'm a
good person you know like I found
like if I'm not always doing trying to
do something good then nobody will think
that I'm an okay person or maybe even an
okay person and I think some of that
goes from when I was young I just never
felt seen you know I never felt seen
when I was a child I just never felt
seen I never had any feedback on what I
was doing or who I was I just never felt
I just you know I felt like you know I
just wasn't seen by my parent my mom
parents I wasn't seen you know and when
you're not seeing you don't you things
aren't recognized so then you you start
running at a frantic pace because
there's no one telling you okay hey you
know you don't have to always be trying
to do something for people to think
you're somebody that does something you
can sometimes not do something and
people are still gonna think that you're
somebody that does something because of
your history of trying to do stuff but
when nobody tells you that you just keep
showing up and feeling like you have to
do stuff and it's and I don't feel like
I need validation I don't feel like
that's what I'm looking for or and some
of this is stuff I don't know it's just
like stuff I've just been thinking about
um but I just like if I don't keep doing
stuff then I just then I just feel like
I don't know what I'm doing that I'm not
doing anything or something I don't know
when some of that sasada fact of not
being seen I just never felt seen as a
child I felt alive I felt but I just
never felt I don't know I
to feel like nobody knew who I was and I
didn't even know and some of that is and
I'm not angry at my parents I'm not
angry I'm but some of that is a parent's
responsibility to connect with the child
on the level where the child sees them
and you know lets them know that they're
okay and just and they feel seen you
know they feel understood they feel I
don't know I just keep coming back to
this word feeling seen somebody said it
the other day in a meeting and they said
that you know they never felt seen by
their parents in and it just man
something made me just like unlocked and
just and I just was like wow that's
something that I always felt I'd never
felt seen you know I just like I just
want you to see me you know is what I
would think to my mother I just want you
to see me you know like what do I have
to do to make you see me you know I just
want to be okay I just I just want you
to see me you know but I need to do some
stuff to take better care of myself I'm
thinking about maybe even taking a
vacation over Valentine's and doing some
but thank you for thinking of me that's
very sweet of you and that just shows
what kind of people nurses are and I
love you let's take this call right here
hey man this past weekend I so I got
fired from job up after five years but
I'm really just calling to like I'm
sorry to hear that man five years is a
good run though most people don't work
somewhere for five minutes you know some
people they don't work at Popeye's long
enough to grill up a damn wing or
something
so congratulations dude oh what the
collar the collar I just want to thank
all your callers because like I'm doing
pretty well all things considered you
know you guys that guy who last week you
called in and you got hit by a car or a
bus or something after he lost his job
and you know it it sucks it [ __ ]
sucks
but it well I'd rather get hit by a bus
at least a bus you get hit by a group of
people you know so at least it's more I
think community or unit a car you get
hit by one [ __ ] dude who's reaching
for a dr. pepper or Diet Sprite and he
ain't paying attention he [ __ ] Clips
you out and I got hit by a Trans Am a
silver Trans Am when I was young
beautiful car broad but still doesn't
matter man I hurt all work it's because
because your show man that right now I
got my chin up and and I'm pretty
optimistic and so the ice wanted us I
just want to thank you and all in all
your callers and because because I'm I'm
optimistic about moving on to something
else and and yeah and you know and I
really think that your podcast has
played a real real part in that I'm not
feeling that I that I have right now if
you're motivated to move on to something
new and so yeah I just want to call to
say thank you well thank you man and I
wish you good luck with that new
experience do you sound yeah if you're
aware and your stay just stay in the
pocket you know and just ask the world
for a new something new and you're gonna
you're gonna you're gonna you're going
to get it you're gonna get it you know
it sound like you're a hard worker
you're committed you don't think that
the world wants you in a good place with
a good job that you're gonna enjoy and
thrive in yes I believe that it does man
and you're gonna get there and and thank
you for calling him because you saying
that that lifts other people up it's
just a circle man we're just caught in a
neat circle that we all you know are uh
we're all here holding together though
the round edges off as a group and it's
pretty cool best of luck to you man with
the new with the new experience and I
can't wait to see what you get I bet
it's gonna be awesome you know somebody
was gonna do an episode of the of the
man up pilot The Comedy Central pilot
and like at the last minute they bail
you know and I was like why and they had
like some obtuse excuses and but in the
end it doesn't matter what their excuses
were you know they didn't want to do it
and it was it kind of hurt my feelings
I'm was somebody I'd done some stuff
born and was like why would you you know
and the reason they made anymore and I
text him and get back to me but fast
forward a few days and we haven't even
better entertainer the two entertainers
who have joined on and it was just what
was supposed to happen and as angry as I
was I remember even I wasn't ad that
angry actually I was upset at first I
was a little bit angry at the person but
then I was like well this is what's
supposed to happen what am I gonna
struggle against what's supposed to
happen for no reason and I kind of
settled down and then something even
greater came along a greater experience
so you just don't know what's right
around that corner man we just don't
know and that corners not gonna show it
to you until we're willing sometimes to
say alright I'm gonna take some faith
and just stand here and wait for
something to come around that corner
rather than to be turning back and
looking at whatever and angry or
whatever it just happened whatever went
away because if I turn back and look
down the wall of a building on the
corner of the side of the court of the
the edge of the corner I'm on then I'm
gonna miss whatever's coming right back
or whatever's coming right around and
we'll miss it
what are you staying there with some
patience some faith some hope man I
think the world wants good things for us
it really does let's take one more call
right here
hey Co this is Ben from Kentucky man I
was just thinking you're always talking
about you know like next with your
sibling and stuff like that I'm I've
been in situation you know where I kind
of uh I grew up away from my sisters and
we've gotten closer you know over the
last few years but I'm in the situation
that where their lives are folks just
crazy like their life they turned into
like these like Street Queens
oh yeah a lot of bad [ __ ] out there
let's hear more working a Waffle House
we're gonna strip club Gang Gang well
you know I get that eggs and cheese and
that raisin toast boy and I want two
scoops of grits son and I want you to
take the hairnet off while you cook it
baby a girl or boy cuz I like my [ __ ]
real you know what I'm saying I like
that waffle have man dude I want that
[ __ ] I wanted a little bit of [ __ ]
methadone sprinkled on them [ __ ]
griot baby and I want that chocolate
meal
I love Waffle House son I want people
[ __ ] fist fighting in the parking lot
when I get there that's cuz I know the
food's gonna be hot you know when people
[ __ ] me you know if people out front
fist fight and they got enough energy in
their belly to fight cuz they've been in
there eating the good hitters at Waffle
House and I want that waffle
I want that perfectly mother [ __ ]
shaped waffle bruh
and I want that thing to taste a little
bit like a waffle and a little bit like
just like nothing but hard air I want
that thing that tastes like it was made
in dang China brother you feel me and I
want that sigh air up on that time I
want that [ __ ] sweet drip drip you
drip drip drip I want that thing all
Arkell that out yeah yeah man and that's
how I like my yeah and I want somebody
to quit I want one of the one of the
cooks to quit while I'm there eating
bruh if somebody [ __ ] quit smush it
tastes better bruh if somebody quits at
the grill my food days even better
I want that an Archie bruh I want that
an Archie going on around me while I'm
enjoying my WH on word
and now the situation is one of my
sisters is when a bad situation where
she actually filed charge against her
boyfriend well we knew that was gonna
happen homework like being kidnapped and
raised and just you know crazy stuff and
my other sisters saying she don't
believe her and kind of blaming each
other and I'm kind of stuck in the
middle I'm trying to be there for both
of them because you know my other sister
she's she's actually she's gonna be like
losing her house she's lost all but he's
in a real bad spot right now cuz she's
afraid to go back to areas because
people are saying she said she's making
this up I was trying to see you know
what would you do far as trying to be
there for folks you know both have stuff
without actually you you know what would
you do to make the right decision there
I appreciate Theo gang gang gang gang
bud you know you know I'll offer some
experience from this I have a sister you
know and uh and she'd been on in and out
of some tough stuff and and you know
whether I can do I can offer I can ask
how can I help and I will let them say
well you could help like this and then I
will say okay that is something I can do
or that is not something I can do what's
another way that I could help that way
you're being of help you're offering to
help and you're offering but there's you
know you're helping on your terms as
well because getting involved too much a
problem made may not be is gonna be less
help in it then than you think you know
you can pray for them you could think
you know you could see if you could
offer them as their weight you know
finance a way that I could help is uh
maybe getting them into a 12-step
program or something like that we're
there then they can develop it to a you
know a way to manage their own lives
better
that's what toil step programs do they
help people manage their own lives
people always give it these names sex
addiction and drug addiction and
alcoholism that's just something outside
that's at accoutrement
the real deal is somebody learning a way
to manage their own life better so you
could offer to go to a meeting with them
but you can't tell them what to do if
they ask for a suggestion you can offer
it you or you could offer a suggestion
you could offer a suggestion and see if
they want a suggestion telling them what
to do isn't gonna help thinking they
should do something nobody should do
anything you know even though we think
it we all think and I think it all the
time somebody should do they should do
they should when I start thinking
somebody should do something something
wrong with me because nobody's gonna do
nothing they're gonna do what they're
gonna do how am I gonna react in it
hopefully not at all cuz it's really
none of my business unless it affects me
too absolutely towards me but I feel
your plight man it's hard to be a loving
brother as your as our sisters get older
because there's only so much we can do
we can't really you know they're not
young girls that we could you know lift
them up onto something or welcome across
the street or you know and sometimes it
won't were younger we don't make the
best choices to help our sisters and so
we feel we should we have to make up for
that as adults you know I remember my
sister I remember I paid one of my
sister's phone bills for a couple years
never really mentioned it oh and now it
is pray for my sister all the time
you know and um and I try to be loving
to other women that I meet I'm not
always successful at it but uh you know
sometimes I try to be loving to other
women that I mean because that's
somebody else's sister and even if I
don't have the relationship or able to
do something for my sister I'm able to
do something for somebody else's that
still do it's the same thing um and I
fail all the time at all of that but
those are just some suggestions of
things but don't be too hard on yourself
there adults as well and they are
responsible for their own lives and you
can just always you can always check in
with them and tell them you love them
and uh and just try and be supportive
even if what they're doing may be the
wrong thing to you
and that's hard to do and that's
unconditional love I think if we can do
that and somebody tells you to doing
something like now you should be doing
this say oh wow you can say how's that
working out what's going on with that oh
cool
good luck if there's anything I can do
to help let me know
but it sounded your hearts in the right
place man and I bet you'll be fine and
this was a great way in this episode I
got to go be on stage in 53 minutes so
I'm gonna shut this down and I'm not
playing that song again on the way out
we'll just we'll finish with a little I
got this one I don't know if we covered
everything at all man you know sometime
I don't know I don't know what we're
doing but I had a good time I had a
great time here in Columbus man I'm
gonna miss some of this no I wanted to
be able to see more of it and play
around in it or do something like that
you know but I guess I'm not gonna have
that experience but thank you to
everybody that came out I thought you're
someone's gonna tell you guys but I
don't know we'll see I'll see you over
the rainbow with Dorothy and that little
dumb that Shih Tzu or whatever you know
come daddy's gonna have SRAM yeah ma but
thank you so much man I feel so grateful
to have people come out to my shows that
genuinely I can tell care about me and
um you know and I care about you too man
whoever you are and if nobody's told you
that they love you man I love you or
woman I love you and uh you know we're
we're
out here on this ball of dirt and water
and we just have these weird just you
know we're emotional creatures but we're
gonna be okay one foot in front of the
other that's all we could do and be
brave to change to to make some changes
if we can't you know nothing changes if
nothing changes so love you guys man be
good to yourselves you deserve it I know
you do